l'immigration reste au coeur de
l'actualité ce soir le maire de
montfermeil dans la seine saint denis a
repoussé de deux mois la décision de
supprimer les crédits de fonctionnement
à deux écoles maternelles de sa commune
le problème de fond reste le même selon
lui la surpopulation immigrés oui le
maire de montfermeil demande ainsi au
gouvernement un débat national sur ce
problème
l'établissement d'une charte des droits
et des devoirs des immigrés au delà de
ce sursis de deux mois
et dans le cas d'une réponse les deux
écoles de montfermeil seront donc privés
des crédits de fonctionnement
certes chi minh tu pas revenus sur leur
décision
je n'ai fait qu'un report dans le temps
pierre bernard ne désarment pas la
décision prise par le maire ces derniers
jours reste donc d'actualité
seul élément nouveau elle ne sera pas
appliqué le 6 novembre prochain date de
la rentrée scolaire sursis ou ultimatum
quoi qu'il en soit pierre bernard a
donné deux mois aux pouvoirs publics
avant d'appliquer ces mesures couper les
moyens de fonctionnement les deux
maternelles où sont inscrits contre le
gré du maire des enfants immigrés
ensuite l'exclusion des directrices des
établissements concernés
entre le 6 novembre 89 et le 6 janvier
90 on ne sait si la situation sera
vraiment très différentes
en tout cas car bernard sort maintenant
du terrain scolaire il ya pas de
problèmes scolaires
non le problème sans problème
d'immigration il faut bien des unions de
la même chose
montfermeil c'est un problème
d'immigration et là dessus je tiens fort
et ferme sur les prix je ne serai pas et
les prix sont élevés le maire exige de
nouveau dans une lettre adressée au
préfet l'arrêt immédiat de toute
attribution de logements aux étrangers
avec consultation préalable de la
municipalité principalement dans la cité
des bosquets de montfermeil
le préfet de seine saint denis répond
que la rénovation de ces quartiers est
une priorité et que des décisions
seraient prises prochainement peut-être
un embryon de solution est on allé trop
loin dans une expérience